Many message mutations causing osteogenesis imperfecta, are good examples
of loss of function alleles that are actually dominant. Now,
living with OI isn't easy, even for the people that
love and support them. For example, some individuals have been
falsely accused of physical abuse. Because they aren't aware
that the individual suffers from OI. And that they're at
a much higher risk for bone fractures. Now currently there's
no cure for OI. So most therapies and treatments essentially
try to improve mobility and reduce the risk
of fracture. And like the Achondroplasia example, the function
of collagen is so important that mutant alleles
are not found in homozygous condition, because it's lethal